[Musica]
e quello che
abbiamo sentito fino a questo momento è
stata l'esaltazione del genio di un
eroismo della mente della creatività che
di solito noi leghiamo all'individualità
il genio è sempre uno il genio è sempre
unico perché il modo in cui è geniale è
solo suo
quindi quello che io sto per dirvi potrà
sembrarvi un po contro narrativo
rispetto a quello che abbiamo sentito
fino adesso perché leonardo grande nume
tutelare di questa assise è l'uomo che
incarna se vogliamo la sintesi di ogni
genio del suo tempo e anche del nostro
oserei dire perché geni così ne abbiamo
visti pochi io invece vorrei cominciare
a riflettere su un inversione del
paradigma diciamo così ragionare anziché
sulla sintesi del genio sul genio della
sintesi cioè come coordinare la
molteplicità delle creatività di tante
persone che hanno visione specialità
competenze che presi singolarmente geni
non sono ma genialmente possono lavorare
insieme
naturalmente il parto per fare questo
ragionamento dalla materia del mio
mestiere che sono le storie è tutta la
nostra vita è costellata di storia da
quando nasciamo ci seguono fino a che
cambiamo le storie occupano le librerie
occupano gli schermi grandi e piccoli
sin dall'infanzia però non sono un
materiale neutro noi ci abitiamo lì
dentro
ma per raccontare è necessario prima
scegliere cosa raccontare è il primo
dato che bisogna rilevare che la
stragrande maggioranza delle storie di
cui noi siamo formati sono storie di
personaggi solitari
io ricordo la mia infanzia pollicino
abbandonato dalla famiglia nel bosco che
già li è un trauma no e deve tornare a
casa lo fa con la mollica la fiaba o
metta il fatto che a casa non lo
vogliano l'abbiano appunto abbandonato
nel bosco dolce remi che di famiglie ne
perde addirittura a 2 vedo molti giovani
presenti che non sanno di cosa sto
parlando questo mi fa sembrare
improvvisamente vecchia ma mi consola il
fatto che vi sia stata risparmiata
la tragedia di dolce remi o li han
povera orfanella simpatica e per carità
è però anche league sola come un cane
che poi la sua gentilezza attira della
simpatia intorno a lei ma parliamo
sempre di una ragazzina la cui il cui
principale dato di trama e la solitudine
potrei citarne altri ma vedi risparmio
per già visto intristendo entro i 6 anni
queste storie erano già nel mio
immaginario io che non avevo neanche la
fortuna di essere unica come figlia mi
ritrovavo appunto con mio fratello
dovevamo dividerci il tentativo di
essere speciali ciascuno a suo modo
tuttora gli a volte lo chiamo l'altro
figlio di mia mamma per sentirmi un po
speciale
secondo quelli che erano gli schemi
della mia infanzia crescendo le cose non
sono migliorate io venivo dalla famiglia
cattolica quindi avevo anche le schede
della bibbia a cui attingere le storie
della bibbia c'è mosè balbuziente ma
tuttavia ha scelto da dio l'unico che
parla con dio può guidare il popolo di
israele alla terra promessa
poi c'è davide re pastore che a tempo
perso componeva anche salumi quindi
anche qui siamo sul genio multitasking
cioè sansone che combatte i filistei con
una forza sovrumana e via batte con non
si capisce perché una mascella d'asino
tutte queste figure si arriva fino a
gesù cristo
la specialità religiosa assoluta il più
solitario dei solitari che solo sulla
croce alla fine ci muore e a 14 anni mi
iscrivo al liceo classico si lo so
sembra una vicenda veramente tragica ma
in parte lo è
credo che collimi però con l'esperienza
nell'immaginario di tutti al liceo
classico mi arriva addosso tutta l'epica
per intero
achille semidio indistruttibile
invincibile se non fosse per quel
piccolo particolare che comunque nemmeno
lui sa bene dove agamennone feroce
guerriero che arriva al punto di cinismo
di sacrificare la figlia pur di
procacciarsi un buon vento che porti le
sue navi fino a [ __ ] e poi ulisse certo
un viaggiatore dead
che sconfigge il minotauro dentro il
labirinto e orfeo il l'investigatore
degli inferi che va per il suo amore
fino a dove vivono i morti in generale
sempre figure solitarie se andavo al
cinema la cosa non cambiava è solo
supereroe batman solo come batman credo
neanche pollicino e superman cioè sempre
drammi familiari alle spalle sempre fino
a luke skywalker dentro il quale scorre
potente la forza per arrivare a harry
potter bambino magico che è destinato a
combattere contro è quello che non può
essere nominato non lo nomineremo
neanche qui ecco tutte queste storie
sono una sequenza di vicende che
corrispondono tutte lo stesso schema
figura solitaria che deve affrontare da
solo tutto il mondo o comunque un
pericolo davvero molto grande e salva
moltitudini in genere questo tipo di
eroe e lo fa in forza di un potere di
una specialità di una genialità che è
tutta sua
non fatevi ingannare dal fatto che
questi abbiano degli amici intorno non
sono storie corali se muore ron weasley
la storia di harry potter continua se
muore harry potter della storia di ruiz
lei non ce ne frega niente
quindi quando vi dicono am avevano degli
amici si chiamano figure gregarie quel
tipo di schema lo ha già analizzato
quando ha fatto appunto le scansioni
della favola prof
si chiama viaggio dell'eroe quelle
figure sono appunto figure di supporto
che devono sostenere la missione
dell'eroe fino al compimento del suo
obiettivo ora in mezzo a tutto questo io
mi ricordo anche della frase di bertold
brecht che dice beato il paese che non
ha bisogno di eroi ma come si fa a
credere a questa frase se le storie
degli eroi ci connota non sono le prime
che sentiamo da bambini
le sole che studiamo da ragazzi e le
uniche che ci ispirano da adulti ci
dicono che sono storie educative che
servono a formarci il carattere ma
esattamente a che cos'è che educano io
lo so lo so perché lo vedo vedo di cosa
è fatta la nostra società costruita
sulla base di
molte strade solitarie xfactor l'idea
che tutto quello che si trova di
benfatto al mondo sia dovuto
all'eccellenza di singoli speciali e
tutti noi che speciali non siamo ben che
avremmo voluto esserlo non siamo
riusciti a ottenere lo stesso risultato
possiamo solo ammirarlo
eccole storia dell'eroe studiate in
questo modo sono storie ammirevoli
ma non sono storie imitabili ecco io
penso che questa cosa non sia vera ma
non è vero e proprio nella storia ma
neanche nell'epica è vera la presa di
[ __ ]
se ci si fosse dovuti fidare
dell'invincibilità di achille della
spietatezza di agamennone quei due
cretini sarebbero ancora ciascuno nella
sua tenda odiando l'altro perché ha
dovuto rinunciare alla sua schiava per
l'orgoglio dell'altro eroe per quei due
che litigarono appunto per la questione
briseide criseide [ __ ] non l'avrebbero
presa mai
c'è voluto ulisse che ha avuto un'idea
geniale e ha detto forse se ci mettiamo
insieme facciamo una cosa che faccia
appunto la sintesi delle nostre
genialità e anche delle nostre
cretinerie in modo che un po si stemperi
per il principio delle cretinerie
comunicanti anche il genio e
comunicativo ma anche un po la scemenza
lo è e dice il cavallo di [ __ ] e questa
roba qua il cavallo di [ __ ] fa cadere
l'invincibile [ __ ] e quella vittoria è
di tutti proprio perché nessuno nessun
eroe di quelle di presenti può dire è
mia e purtroppo le dita così non ce la
raccontano
ho visto che c'è una mostra in questo
momento mentre venivo c'era un cartello
sembrava messo lì tipo candid camera
dice ercole le sue fatiche nella storia
dell'arte tutti i quadri solo dell'eroe
ecco le storie collettive non ce le
racconta nessuno eppure è pieno siamo
circondati pensate a wikipedia
quanti di voi qui hanno scritto una voce
di wikipedia
qualcuno c'è qualcuno c'è tra i presenti
ecco qualcuno c'è di chi prende la
storia collettiva non ci ricordiamo
magari i fondatori sappiamo che un'opera
che richiede e ottiene il contributo di
milioni di persone nel mondo un sapere
condiviso
penso a messico 68 quei due corridori
assieme al bianco che di supporta con un
gesto tutto suo che il tempo di un inno
nazionale col pugno alzato in alto
portano nelle case di tutto il mondo il
tema della discriminazione razziale
penso alla macchina di turing lo sforzo
di molti cervelli insieme da gli
scacchisti ai matematici che riescono
come di ade a decifrare il codice dei
nazisti ea far fare un salto di qualità
enorme la guerra che in quel momento
forse senza di loro sarebbe stata persa
queste storie non vengono raccontate la
prima volta che io ho incontrato una
storia che mi ha cambiata è stato quando
ho conosciuto i ragazzi della via paal
di ferenc molnar gruppi di ragazzi che
si incontrano per il controllo di un
quartiere
certo poi nemecek muore è stato il primo
lutto della mia vita ma anche lì c'era
qualcosa che non tornava
erano tutti maschi e ripetevano lo
schema della guerra per il controllo di
un territorio quel modello di potere e
il modello che passano quelle storie un
modello sottrattivo dove se tu lo
possiede
e perché l'hai rubato a qualcun altro e
quel qualcun altro come diceva
tagliavano si logora la seconda volta
che ho visto una storia collettiva però
è cambiato tutto
a 16 anni ho letto it di stephen king
and it di stephen king è una storia
collettiva dove non c'è dubbio che tutti
i protagonisti siano assolutamente
sfigati
c'è un ciccione bull izzato c'è un
balbuziente c'è un nero non mondo di
bianchi c'è un secchione
c'è un ipocondriaco mammone c'è una
femmina una di quelle che nelle storia
dell'eroe vanno salvate di sicuro non
salvano tutti loro sarebbero morti in
quella storia ma mettendosi insieme
ammazzano it
ecco dopo it io vado in giro a
raccontare ragazzini solo storie
collettive perché non credano di poter
essere potenti solo uno contro l'altro
ma imparino anche che si può essere
potenti insieme
perché alla fine la tempesta è solo un
milione di gocce d'acqua ma con giusto
vento
ecco a voi siete tempesta senza dubbio
grazie